as Holy Week nears an end many people
this morning are looking forward to the
holiest day on the Christian calendar
Easter Sunday more than 70 percent of
Americans identify his Christian but
less than a third practiced regularly
James Brown is at a Baptist Church in
Alexander Virginia where its pastor and
members are defined those odds JB what's
happening
hello Charlie good to hear your voice in
as you can tell I'm here in the
sanctuary of the historic Alpha Street
Baptist Church in Alexandria Virginia
and as you mentioned this 214 year old
church has absolutely no problems with
attendance due in large part to the
hiring back in 2008 of his dynamic young
pastor dr. Howard John Wesley since then
the congregation has nearly tripled
[Music]
it's six o'clock on a Saturday night and
alpha Street Baptist Church is packed
this is one of four services that the
Reverend dr. Howard John Wesley
officiates every weekend he says church
attendance is strong because the church
understands its calling we are called to
be traditional Baptists with a high
liturgy where those who want to come and
receive an intellectual and spirited
worship service can do so in a timely
manner and this congregation has grown
from what size when you first got here
around 2500 now we're just just north of
7,000 in 8 years the challenge from most
churches is attracting young people
while maintaining the core older
membership Alpha Street Baptist does
both and pastor Wesley believes that
it's age 44 and his lineage as a
fourth-generation preacher are keys to
his effectiveness first I am raised in
the era of hip-hop
I respect hip-hop I had no 90s language
so within language I can use analogies
and metaphors that address all
generations in the words of my favorite
poet Shawn Carter
for those over 45 that's jay-z Shawn
Carter argues that a couple dollars
shut up our holler his style and
substance has certainly attracted 15
year old Madison Wellborn he doesn't
make you feel bored or at home or
laid-back he's making you involved in
wanting to be a church and that's
something I really do like and find
great about pastor Isley his most well
received sermons mix contemporary topics
with a biblical message in one sense
Saints I'm outraged in 2012 he gave a
sermon while wearing a hoodie as he
addressed the Trayvon Martin Sheen's
when you're hurt and when you're scared
it's hard to hear the voice of God in
2016 the subject was Beyonce's Grammy
winning album lemonade I didn't come to
preach Beyonce
I came to priest Bible and you can't get
out of the first book of the Bible
without being introduced to a brother
who's got a PhD in lemonade his name is
Joseph we knew the preaching was good
what we didn't know at that time how
good his teaching was deacons James
Garrett and Patricia Wallace led the
committee that hired dr. Wesley eight
years ago and how many applicants did
you get
we had 108 108 applicants yes but hiring
pastor Wesley wasn't without its
challenges at first he turned down the
job but after realizing he made a
mistake
Wesley came to Alpha Street to
personally ask the congregation to
reconsider him the pulpit committee had
given me a list of questions of things
they thought the congregation was gonna
ask and after getting up in humility
saying I made a mistake
you know those questions were asked not
one I think that that that transparency
along with that vulnerability is what
attracts people to be part of the church
[Music]
Alpha Street and pastor Wesley have
grown together in 2015 the church
donated 1 million dollars to the new
African American Museum in Washington DC
in the last two years it has become the
Church of choice for the former first
family on Easter what are you preparing
for this Easter I welcome the president
at all times but also in a Welcome that
homeless men off the street who may be
on Easter Sunday is looking just for a
family of faith to put their arms around
so Charlie with all the multiple
services that are being held here on the
drawing board is a new building which is
a welcome relief to dr. Wesley as a
matter of fact he commented to my
producer Alvin Patrick when Alvin said
but you're a young man you can handle it
and pass the Wesley joke back saying hey
I want to be an old man by the way Alex
and Norah on the guest preaching list is
one with North Carolina roots by the
name of Charlie Rose thanks a read from
the book of lemonade whatever brings
them in you know get the fight you know
when we did our show from the Nashville
African American History Museum I had
heard about this church that got a
million dollars in contributions it
shows how strong that community is thank
you so much for that story JB and Alan